bismillah al hamdulillah assalamualaikum
welcome back to another episode of the
Dean show we're here every week same
time same Channel you can visit the Dean
show calm to see our show times or you
can view us as people do from all around
the globe at the Dean show calm today
we're going to be let you get involved
in this show you've seen it last time
it's back again dunya dunya we're going
to let you get involved your family
we're going to read out some of the
different questions and we're going to
let our next guest when we come back let
us know is this dunya dunya does it
qualify under that and the non-muslims
we want you to get involved too so if
you see a Muslim doing something that's
not according to Islam you can nicely
smile at them and say dunya dunya and
this may be a pimp get his act together
so then we can all live in peace because
if we're doing things the way our
Creator wants us to do it that's how
we're going to have peace when we come
when we come back siraj wahhaj helping
us tackle dunya dunya right back on the
Dean show ya allah there's only one
how is His Messenger oh la la la la
o Allah there's only one but Jesus was
his messenger no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice I said
I male call it comes to the heading
peace be unto you peace be upon you how
are you doing doing great things be told
how you do it thank you very much people
have they can see you have your own
section at the Dean show so they can go
there see some of the shows that we've
done in the past and we're really
thankful that you out of your busy
schedule you find the time to to be with
us so I want to thank you eddie not only
on behalf of myself what on behalf of
all your guests you know we have an
opportunity people have an opportunity
even myself i watch your show come to
never opportunity to go and see some of
your guests that you've had and it is
very educational very informative and
and also entertaining hello
entertainment how loud entertainment yes
and that's what we try to do we tried to
give the non-muslims a better picture
about Islam to litigate some of the
false fears and clear up some of the
misconceptions and also to help educate
the Muslims with people who are
qualified to talk about this beautiful
way of life yes it is Islam the way of
life of all the messages of God
absolutely now just a little bit about
yourself you were actually the first
Muslim to open up in Congress is that
true how will be offered by our guest
chaplain imam siraj massage member of
the american muslim council washington
DC siraj wahhaj of brooklyn new york
he's the first muslim leader to work in
cooperation with new york city police
department and he is nationally known
for his leadership and establishing a
drug-free zone in the drug gladden
neighborhood his neighborhood of
bedford-stuyvesant in new york in the
name of god most gracious most merciful
praise belongs to the alone Oh God the
Lord and church of all the world's
praise belong today we shaped us and
colored us in the wounds of our mothers
colored us black and white brown red and
yellow praise belong to thee who created
us from males and females and made us
into nations and tribes that we may know
one another most gracious most merciful
all-knowing all-wise just God master of
the Day of Judgment thee alone we
worship and from the alone do we seek
help guide the leaders of this nation
who have been given a great
responsibility in worldly affairs guide
them and grant them righteousness and
wisdom guide them and us on the straight
path the path of those whom thou hast
bestowed by favors the path of your
inspired servants the path of Noah
Abraham Moses Jesus and Muhammad guide
them and us not on the path of the
disobedient ones yes talk about this for
a second yeah it is interesting that
most people don't realize that Congress
never opens up a session without an
invitation from some clergy usually it's
done by some Jewish rabbi or Christian
minister so for the first time in
history of the United States of America
and Imam a Muslim leader actually did an
invocation open up the session of
Congress I think was nineteen
ninety-three of mistaken I think we're
seeing that now I think they're seeing
this right now this is you is that what
that's all right i was a little bit
younger bit huh you know still looking
good looking good hamdullah so i think
that's important i think what happened i
found out that that day in the next day
in saudi arabia almost every five
minutes that played huh because it was
important it was important for the
Muslims around the world 1 billion 500
million Muslims for them to see that
Muslims in America are part of America
when we were American citizens and we're
part of this nation and so to
acknowledge that presence to have a
Muslim Imam
open up a session of Congress was huge
let me tell how big it was was so big
that everybody wasn't for it I I forgot
his name on dumb Pat 700 club huh he
said he was angry that a Muslim opened
up a session of Congress he's got this I
said he says what next you have which is
doing it so he was he was very upset
it's pretty childish right childless man
jobs you know as if that as if the
Muslims are not legitimate yeah
religious people yeah i mean you're
talking about again 1400 years old the
old 1400 years ago the Quran was
revealed and you talk about all of these
followers all over the world and for him
to get upset that means to open up a
session of Congress yeah surprising this
is not how you work towards peace I mean
this man that you mentioned i hope we
pray that god almighty guides him yes
because if we have people working
towards you know harmony and peace we
won't talk i think that people like you
have done the job of explaining islam
bringing muslim personalities and
scholars to talk about islam and let the
people see and and have conversations we
ought to have dialogue and discussions
so people have misconceptions about
islam then then it need to be clarified
yeah he needs to watch the danger yeah
and then maybe we get a copy of the tape
when we sin we could talk with them you
know dialer we've nothing to hide I
think Platt promises leave from that
mistake yeah yes so you have nothing to
hide of course exactly tell us now also
before we go into dunya dunya you've
also gotten a lot of rewards from the
community you've done some great
community work you have clean up some of
the drug infested areas crime now one of
the area's one of the areas on where I'm
the Imam measure the top walk yeah we
first opened up that measured in 1978
according to the the captain of the 79
precinct which is the area captain like
the main police chief yeah he said that
it was it was one of the worst in the
city but after him they allowed the
Muslims we had our anti-drug patrol in
about nineteen eighty eight
Allah blessed us to close down 15 crack
houses on the block of the masjid don't
while dope dope houses crack houses and
and ran the drug dealers and the drugs
out of our community and if you look at
the area now you compare it to 1978 to
now it was an area of blight abandoned
buildings you know when we went there
1978 there was not one Muslim business
you go there now you know buildings no
abandoned buildings no crack houses and
over 50 Muslim businesses in that area
of the message it alone and non-muslims
can come into your mouth I have to talk
to you and you didn't know about the
domes and they do not only people in the
area we have law enforcement we have
political people we have religious
people yeah coming into the message and
having a dialogue a conversation but
with the Muslim that's how we get to
know each other that's how we get so we
can live in peace love and peace we all
want the same thing I no more peace when
we come back get ready for dunya dunya
here on the Dean show oh yeah oh yeah
they're good so if you find yourself
your Iman is going down check yourself
there is none woody to be worship except
Allah alone you got some serious and
music in the car bobbing your head the
50 Cent's oh no it's common sense don't
do things that can hurt people Lady Gaga
googoo and all that other nonsense
bullying is haraam backbiting slandering
and such subsistence as smoking state
route 18 inch bar except we'll see what
happens to Eddie on the D show and we
holdin it down on a Dean show Fairly
make sure y'all tune it comes to you the
truth and the attribute of the one who
created you that he's one and alone
running this universe that he doesn't
become born he doesn't die he doesn't
eat and go to the bathroom this is not
God problem cares yeah is this doesn't
make sense who was Jesus worshipping
resists recorded in the Gospels despite
all of the other issues about the
Gospels you put those aside with the
Saints mentioned there with Jesus
worship God one protects us from hunger
with imam siraj and the Dean show dunya
dunya now get ready and if you see that
now you can take this to your local Imam
to your scholar and ask them so this is
really qualify for dunya dunya and then
you actually define what do we mean
before we know what do we mean when we
say dunya what does this mean you see
that's really it's a great question yeah
when you talk about dunya everything in
this life is is doing it yeah right the
food we eat is done yet control then we
wear television programs even your
television program it's not done yet I
mean don't you I mean you know it's not
the hair after this life here and
everything in the doing is not bad yeah
but sometime it has a negative
connotation and we say oh that's the
dunya that's implying that that's
something that's not good that you don't
take in you know taking consideration
the afterlife you you know you want to
do things that's going to be beneficial
in this life as well as the hair after
so sometimes Muslim say you know that's
the doing it that's what they do in the
dunya you know so it's a negative
connotation yeah so we want to balance
it out so we have to be in this world
you have a bit of like the Prophet peace
be upon us to be like a traveler huh
there you go yeah now tell us when
Friday Juma rolls around the brother
rather be downtown talk about this now
don't ya dunia he weighs city anyway
very deep in dunya don't yet bigger yet
now elaborate on this the importance of
Gemma and why this qualifies for dunya
dunya can you gotta realize that the
lord of the world is telling us
something you can go do what you want to
do but friday at a certain time it's
time for us to go to the masjid for
congregational prayer that's the house
of its the house of worship the houses
were shot is called bait so a lot of the
house of God yeah it's you know if we
were Christians it would be the church
if we choose to be the synagogue yeah
but it's the master it's the mosque it's
the place where Muslims go to pray to
God and and and we required on fridays
at a certain time
to congregate ourselves together and go
to the masjid and those who would not go
to the masjid to go do something else
whatever they doing is dunya unless it
has something to do with the health the
hospital so forth and so on but we're
told that when when that day comes we
should leave off all trade and business
and hastens to the remembrance of allah
the almighty after all after all he
created us and gave us even the dunya
that we have the dunya car that we have
been doing your clothing that we have
everything he gave us the brain the
brains that we have the body that we
have the jobs that we have and he's
saying okay for about one hour a week
stop all of that yeah income and
remember me that's not too hard for the
one that's giving you everything
everything is very easy you haven't even
stopped you can't stop for a moment to
go to the master towards the God who
gives you the air that you that you that
you breathe water that you drink the
beautiful wife that you have and the
children that you have the parents that
you have you mean to tell me you can't
spend some time glorifying him you've
probably heard it all I mean you are the
as I say the og oh oh I the original
Imam so tell us some of the some of the
excuses that you know you sitting there
and you're here and you're just like you
know on your head you say man talk to us
give it share it some example some
stories about some excuses and then
maybe the after some good you know
advice you know talking to these people
that maybe they turned around or what
happened you know you have every excuse
yeah you know from what I gotta make my
money money the dollar good old dollar I
gotta make money and I'm saying that the
God knows that you need to make money
and he'll test you yeah I mean I know
you know Muslim businesses who make a
sacrifice yeah and maybe that one hour
perhaps they lost some sales but in the
end you really win by Allah and you get
more from Allah because you are in
obedience with him yeah so you may lose
money and you may not yeah
some people who actually make more money
so god knows best so they want to spend
time with their girlfriends which
there's no such thing as girlfriends and
Islam now you know so they want to do
anything they want to go to the movies
they want to go it heard every kind of
excuse but really simply there is no
excuse in the worship of God the
Almighty and again you can you know some
of the things you want to do you can do
but after and Allah says and after then
after the prayer didn't go you go back
you go back to your business go back to
your doing your business go back to
making money you can do it but there
should be a time that you shouldn't same
thing with the Jews yeah Jews were given
a command about the Sabbath that on that
day they had to stop they couldn't work
yeah you know so it's not something
that's just unique to the Muslims but
all of religious people many Christians
they they close down their businesses on
Sunday yeah so they go to the church on
Sunday Jews go to the synagogue on
Saturday Muslim go to the master on
Friday and all of them in the process of
doing what remember remembering that
their creator and then you got people
don't want to do it okay fine do what
you want to do you're not gonna make you
do it and that it's what I have Sedin
there's no compulsion in religion but
there's a price that you're gonna have
to pay you'll die you're gonna die and
he may even give you a long life yeah
that's not even the issue but in the end
in the end you know it's gonna be held
accountable accountable for what we did
and what we didn't do he asks us to do a
simple thing and again by the way and
you go to jummah prayer and the
congregational prayer on friday who
benefits you can't you can't benefit god
that's the thing that people have to
understand you can't benefit him if if
nobody in creation worships him it
doesn't take anything away from this
kingdom and everybody in the Universe
worship God together all day long does
not add to him it doesn't add to his
power or anything like that he doesn't
need us we need him and so when we every
every every week on a Friday and we give
him one hour and we remember him it's
good
it's good to get out of the dunya yeah
for a while you know the rat race right
to get to get involved in in remembrance
of him and then you be shocked you go to
the masjid you listen to the sermon the
Imam gives a a hood bob or sermon and it
says something that will change your
life even help you and your dunya you'll
help you in your big help in your
business yeah that's the point and you
know you get a so much edge of and so
much reward from Allah the Almighty for
doing what he commands us to do your
life is more blessed more more much more
blessed absolutely we're going to be
right back with another question and let
you decide dunya dunya or not we'll be
right back on the D show oh yeah oh yeah
I am not afraid to stand alone if a las
bombas I i am not afraid to stand alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if a las
vacas I i am not afraid to stay alone I
am Not Afraid of shadow
different lines by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone
is the medina coming to the truth
requires two things that requires deep
thinking that you've already done but it
requires another step and that's courage
if you have the truth but you don't have
courage you won't stand up for the truth
and that's as good as standing up for
falsehood I would say this thing that
you're just told me it's not in the
scripture and they would say a marginal
note added by a scribe yeah okay we know
that and I'd be thinking if you know
this is not the Bible why are you
preaching it as if it's gospel truth
from hunger
in show with imam siraj wahhaj on this
episode dunya dunya let's read off the
next one and then we'll see if this
qualifies for dunya dunya now you'll be
ready to and everybody collaborate and
if something you have some doubts take
it to your local Imam take it to your
scholar and see if he'll agree with us
to the main thing is that we're sincere
and then we want to change for the
better doing things how the crater wants
us to do it then nothing less than
paradise is that right absolutely
alright when the Muslim convenience
store owner has been advised and talked
to many times about selling alcohol
lotto tickets in the inner cities and
all he has to say in response is this is
America brother this is America what do
we have to say don't you know yeah oh
yeah oh yeah big dunya that's what a big
G Apple to the capital on you let me say
this idea I think it's important that
the the beautiful thing about our
religion the Prophet peace and blessings
be upon one said in an halala bu noon
we're in the haram abay you noon bobina
home an omalu Mustafa haughton la Yamuna
Cathedral milanesa that which is
permissible is as plain it's clear clear
that which is not permissible it's clear
but in between them are doubtful matters
not many people know about yeah right so
so there are some issues that is very
very clear this issue here selling
alcohol I don't care where you are it's
not committed this crime there's no
ambiguities no loyalty it's not like
well you know I'm not really sure really
it could no no it is absolutely
prohibited now now I know for a fact
that these people who sell alcohol in
lotto tickets and and all those other
things but getting a lot of tickets what
about that is that clear that that's
under gambling so the gambling yeah it's
clear again it's not there's no
ambiguity there and don't these things
destroy people's lives it does it also
destroys life you know
you have a basketball player recently
for the for the Washington Wizards I
think his name is arenas got in trouble
lost and I've you know he has a contract
with over a hundred thousand dollars but
he was gambling with another person on
it on his owners and it was on the team
and somebody didn't pay the debt right
they were gambling yeah and the koran
talks about it brings enmity alcohol and
gambling when he do take out a gun wow I
pull guns on each other uh-huh pull guns
on each other and now he's suspended
from the from the NBA cuz they heard
about it huh right so you have gambling
it's a serious addiction you have you
have one of the great baseball plays p
trolls yeah who you know is a
hall-of-famer a baseball played one of
the best best ever but he can't get into
the Hall of Fame because used to gamble
and it's the gamble in baseball yes
that's a no-no you have people that have
lost millions of dollars gambling when
the great basketball plays Michael
Jordan had a game gambling problem
Charles Barkley great basketball player
has it has a gambling addiction admitted
gambling addiction here so these things
are clear now you're Muslim now you are
supposed to be a good example for the
people in America yeah people should
call our people New York the people in
Philadelphia you supposed to be a good
example now here you're making money you
making money off the people but the
people don't even know that you're not
supposed to be selling those things
you're not supposed to be some alcohol
alcohol is it's been implicated and i
think one third of the accidents that
have fatal accidents in this country
attributed to alcohol on one third of
the people who commit suicide a tribute
attributed to alcohol you talk about
murder and all alcohol so how can you
and muslim say that you want the good
for the people you're they're making a
lot of money off of the people but God
told you don't don't need the profits
that you can't go down
allow you to sell galco not only don't
drink it but don't sell it so so no it
is dunya of the worst kind yeah and I'm
saying to any Muslim if you want to be a
successful businessman then do what God
tell you to do I know some Muslims I'm
very proud of them I used to go talk to
them they sold alcohol I remember once
going into a Muslim store was a Sunday
right yeah and I got excited I saw a
sign and it says that um no alcohol sold
here nice huh on Sunday Oh after three
o'clock yesterday huh so the rest of the
time it's there at sea and I first saw
no alcohol sold here I got excited
excited but something's I'm stipulation
now then I looked and I saw on Sundays
so but but a Muslim is like okay this
listen mr. mr. Jones comes into the
store and I want some I want some bear
almost Joan I don't have beer well let
me go somewhere else but before you go
on let me tell you something yeah you
asked me what i'm not selling their you
because i know the bear is not good for
you with our opportunity wonderful
opportunity and i know it's not good for
you clear I'm not gonna sell it for you
even though I don't make your money from
you but I'm not gonna sell it to you
because I don't want it to hurt you
uh-huh that's what you that's what we
ought to be about inviting the good it's
about helping the people to stay away
from those evil exactly destroy your
lives anyway absolute we'll be right
back with more dunya dunya you be the
judge you decide here on the Dean show
do ya do ya mean he's did you say that
you're not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of us and I'm you can
not be a Muslim is attended our faith to
believe in and love Jesus Christ by
b is the fruit why is it then when it
comes to one of the most important
decisions in life we literally abuse
ourselves it's not that the main thing
we're looking forward to see what type
of money he has so that he can treat my
daughter like a princess it's not about
the one from hunger
back on a Dean
also tell us Imam could are non-muslims
brothers in humanity because they're our
brothers in humanities is right
absolutely we wanted to be our brother
after one week I want you be clear about
them yeah Quran says in many places yeah
you're a nurse oh man kinds of God is
talking to all of us yeah so tell us our
brothers and humanity the non-muslims
after they see now they know dunya dunya
and they walk up into this convenience
store and they see the big Kaaba and
they see all the alcohol they say okay
there must be a Muslim can they tell
them the non-muslim to the Muslim now
that they know that it shouldn't be
selling alcohol I think it's what could
I tell them dunya I want them to say I
want them to talk I want them to say
don't you doing it yeah I want them to
remind them I want them to embarrass
them and sometimes you be surprised
Eddie that if a non-muslim it says so
Muslim you know what bad enough that I'm
not a Muslim or not I don't practice
Islam when you should know better you
Muslim you're supposed to be an example
you study the Koran you believe in
Prophet Muhammad and and and people I
want them to do that I want them to call
us to an account and it's some time by
the way sometimes I do that yeah you're
supposed to be a Muslim yeah yeah yeah
love it I love it yeah hey we need to
call him to account I I you know I want
one of the plans that I had from New
York side I was my objective to get
every Muslim store in New York City to
stop selling alcohol yeah and I'm going
to do it one day by God's permission oh
yeah you know I'm going to try to get
rid of the girly magazines yeah Nona me
maybe I magazines the porno and I was a
lot of photography get rid of alcohol
get rid of the gambling yeah and all of
that and I think that if we would do
that we will send a strong message to
the people America that you know what
those muslims are they're serious and
they for real otherwise you know you
know what they're going to say you just
like everybody else yeah and you worse
you know why you worried because you
hypocrite because at least at least
they'll say we just what we do but you
you you gonna get your own tears so
hopefully those Muslims who are doing
that now you can use this episode and
along with your
calling them advising them in the nicest
ways to stop this hopefully something a
law do the rest and they'll stop and
those liquor stores or those places will
turn into maybe some bread stores or
some other pocket doors an idea how
about those people who watch the show
make a copy of this tape give it to
build Muslims that's a great idea on Oh
stow lake a copy giving us a listen to
the Muslims who are selling alcohol and
the non-muslims can also help out and
participate they tell them dunya doing
that last one yes now the person that's
always concerned about smelling good and
looking nice disqualified under dunya
dunya no no no no no like sweet smelling
the Prophet love those opposed this is
good has a good thing it's good to
smells good what you got oh there's been
little bit careful okay about the women
yeah until what happened once I wasn't
one on a plane right huh and I and I was
walking down the aisle and all of a
sudden my head turn is as if someone
pulled my head and I turn and I found
myself looking in the direction don't
you have a whiplash after that almost
just just just just about well in and
you know what did it how's the smell
yeah it was so attractive that I'll just
like I followed it and I think the
person knew that yeah so women the
Muslim women and the women have to be a
little bit careful yeah they don't want
to make the scent too strong yeah it
should be very you know you know very
mild yeah as opposed to being strong and
grabbed attention so that some man could
start looking at yeah so this attention
should be sought after her husband it
should definitely sort of the husband
yeah so she can I mean put whatever she
wants to wear because you know the dress
code and everything is again how the
Creator it has put it down but what
about the the man now also how is he he
can be nice and not wrinkled and have a
nice you know attire on where he is the
part of Islam's little you have to look
like a bum ok this is don't mean you pie
is because you look like nice clothes is
good nice clothes is fine yeah
according to a person's ability person
can't afford it but we should avoid for
men silk fences ya go yeah but but other
than that we should have nice clothing
and neat and clear now we're going to
bring it all home it goes back to
acknowledging that there is one who gave
you life will give you def talk about
this because these things he wants us to
be in paradise he wants what's best for
us so if we look at it from a different
perspective not just a bunch of rules as
I think it'll make more sense please
that's the point that I'm trying to
drive home Eddie is that that God wants
was good yeah and the thing we can't you
know as much as we love this world I
mean we try to stay as long as we can
yeah be my a few people try to kill
themselves yeah most people they want to
live right hand when it's close to death
that's all God don't let me die but he's
got something better than this world
yeah as good as it it is to us there's
something better for instance I
mentioned early in another segment every
soul shall taste of death not in here
after in paradise there's no death yeah
you know there's no sickness you don't
even have to go to the bathroom yeah and
guess what you don't even go to sleep
can you imagine in a world of peace and
tranquility no walls no fighting none of
that stuff nothing but peace and
anything that you want ya know you could
have it yeah in the end of paradise yeah
and God wants us to have that but the
price we have to pay is give up the
dunya give up the dunya dunya don't you
don't you thank you very much thank you
we started with P sweet and with P thank
you may God Almighty Allah reward you
think we need to have you back again
when you go to town it's confirmed it's
comparing what he's heard all the
browser people I'm saying is there are
all these people confirmed back again
next time with us imam siraj wahhaj look
out for that you can visit him at the
Dean show communes own section thank you
for being with us on the Dean show we
want peace the owner peace is the one
who created us and we need to live life
according to how he wants us to live and
then there's nothing less than paradise
as the mom had talked about at the end
we hope that you come back here every
week on the Dean show so we can all
benefit
from this beautiful knowledge that most
of these guests who come on they share
with us we'll see you next time on the
Dean so until then peace be unto you the
dvds for Dawa as allah has said in the
Quran in surah now 16 125 will do elasa
be laid up bookable hikmah to invite all
to the way of your lord with wisdom
beautiful preaching and reason with them
in ways that are best and this is a
great opportunity for you to take up the
obligation take up the call as allah has
told you to do and share this beautiful
message with the world islam submission
to the One God doesn't see what
everyone's talking about if you find one
contradiction it can't be from God but
the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best to give
up for spring guy that's why I will
never give up spreading this message
hope there you take that necessary step
you don't know if you're going to live
till tomorrow
so you got to find that urgency to do
the right thing right now if you say
that you're not believe in Jesus you
have stepped outside of this nun you
cannot be a Muslim is attended our faith
too it's cold it's Leigh everybody
sleeping I arise and ask a lot of
thinking me Omar you see hola you know
all the sins I do I turn to you to
figure my scene tomorrow I'm you seen
for slave you don't my love alone I'm
the one runs away oh look I need